Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. On today's episode, I'm joined by Dr. Josephine Perry, a qualified and regulated sport
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天做客节目的嘉宾是 Josephine Perry 博士，她是一位拥有专业资质的运动
and exercise psychologist. The episode is going to be super useful for you, regardless of which area of psychology you are passionate about. There's loads of useful tips and guidance for performance and mindset. And if you stay tuned right to the end, you might find some interesting tips you've also not considered in the past. I hope you find it so useful. It is slightly longer than usual about 45-50 minutes but it's well worth every second. Enjoy! Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side To be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
与锻炼心理学家。无论你对心理学的哪个领域感兴趣，这期节目对你来说都将非常实用。节目中包含了大量关于表现和心态的实用建议与指导。如果你能坚持听到最后，或许会发现一些你过去从未考虑过的有趣技巧。希望这期节目对你有帮助。本期节目比平时稍长，大约 45-50 分钟，但每一秒都非常值得。尽情享受吧！让这成为你的指南，让这档播客陪伴在你身边，助你走上获得专业资质的道路，这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Today we have a slightly longer than usual episode and we're going to be talking with Dr. Josephine Perry. She's incredibly inspiring to speak with and I feel really humbled and honoured that she gave us her time so freely and it was such a pleasure to speak with her. I hope you'll find it useful. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, welcome along to today's episode. I'm really very excited to introduce you to Dr Josephine Perry. Dr Josephine is a sport and exercise
我是 Marianne Trent 博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我们有一期比平时稍长的节目，我们将与 Josephine Perry 博士进行交谈。与她交谈非常鼓舞人心，她如此慷慨地抽出时间，我感到非常荣幸和谦卑，与她交流真是一种享受。希望你会觉得这期节目很有用。我期待在节目结束后与你再次交流。你好，欢迎收听今天的节目。我非常兴奋地向大家介绍 Josephine Perry 博士。Josephine 博士是一位运动与锻炼
psychologist and also an author. Welcome along, Josephine. Thank you for having me. Thank you for saying yes. I'm really excited to meet you, to get to know you and to help our audience learn more about you and your work, your books and your career. So what is a sport and exercise psychologist? Let's start there. So we are trained, I guess, officially in mental skills. A lot of us now call ourselves performance psychologists because we don't just work in sport and exercise. I have clients who are medics, are entrepreneurs um who are djs opera singers and lots of athletes and it is about helping someone get the absolute best out of themselves
心理学家，同时也是一位作家。欢迎你，Josephine。谢谢你的邀请。谢谢你答应参加。我很高兴能见到你，了解你，并帮助我们的听众更多地了解你、你的工作、你的书籍以及你的职业生涯。那么，什么是运动与锻炼心理学家？我们从这里开始吧。我们受过正式的心理技能训练。现在我们很多人称自己为表现心理学家，因为我们不仅仅在运动和锻炼领域工作。我的客户中有医生、企业家、DJ、歌剧演员，还有许多运动员，我们的工作是帮助人们发挥出自己的最佳水平。
um so that might be through workshops in clubs and i'll go into lots of sports clubs or work with sports scholars in schools um to help teach some kind of general elements we might be working on how to max out your motivation or how to handle performance anxiety and then I also work one-on-one with people to really focus on their specific elements what might be holding them back from where they want to get to how do they keep going I work a lot in endurance sports and my background's they keep going I work a lot in endurance sports and my background is endurance sports so I work a lot with people about how do you manage to do a hundred mile run I've got some doing a hundred mile ultra this weekend it's like how do you keep going for a
这可以通过俱乐部的工作坊来实现，我会去很多体育俱乐部，或者与学校的体育特长生合作，教授一些通用的心理要素。我们可能会研究如何最大化你的动力，或者如何处理表现焦虑。此外，我还与个人进行一对一辅导，专注于他们特定的需求，找出阻碍他们前进的因素，以及如何保持动力。我在耐力运动领域工作很多，我自己也有耐力运动的背景，所以我经常与人们探讨如何坚持完成 100 英里的跑步。我这周末就有一些客户要参加 100 英里的超级马拉松，这就像是问：当你身体的每一个部位都在尖叫着拒绝时，你该如何坚持跑完
hundred miles when every part of your body is screaming no so it's a complete mix of working with teams, helping the teams get better working together and those individuals within the teams and then also working with individuals and helping them get the most out of themselves. Amazing, it sounds like a fascinating area and I'm intrigued intrigued to see how I get beyond three kilometers in a run let alone 100 miles so hats off to your clients that's you know really really impressive stuff how did you get into it? So I had a previous career as a communications director and so until 2013 I was working for a company called or a charity actually called Nuffield Health which was lovely because I was working in the fitness the health world but but running communications running campaigns to get people more active but my heart was in Ironman racing so I was doing long distance triathlons with my husband and we went over to
100 英里？所以，我的工作是团队合作的混合体，帮助团队更好地协作，帮助团队中的个人，同时也与个人合作，帮助他们发挥出最大潜能。太棒了，这听起来是一个迷人的领域。我很好奇，我自己连 3 公里都跑不下来，更别提 100 英里了，所以我向你的客户致敬，这真的非常令人印象深刻。你是怎么进入这个领域的？我之前的职业是传播总监，直到 2013 年，我都在一家名为 Nuffield Health 的公司（实际上是一家慈善机构）工作。那段经历很美好，因为我是在健身和健康领域工作，负责传播和推广活动，鼓励人们多运动。但我真正热爱的是铁人三项，我和丈夫一起参加长距离铁人三项比赛。我们去了
Australia to do Ironman Melbourne and I was standing on the beach in Frankston which is where the swim start is there and the waves looked horrific and I was really really scared and the guy on the tannoy said you can't control those waves you can only control how you feel about them and it was it was proper light bulb moment stuff of me going ah if I used my brain I could be a lot better at this sport stuff because I was always the really geeky academic kid at school and I was always last out of the changing rooms to ever do any sports um and I suddenly realized I could be a lot better at sport if I actually used my brain a bit more and I got in the water and I did the swim and I suddenly realized I could be a lot better at sport if I actually used my brain a bit more and I got in the water and I did the swim and I had my fastest Ironman race um probably ever because I can't see me going back to it and um when I got back to the UK afterwards I really
澳大利亚参加墨尔本铁人三项赛。我站在 Frankston 的海滩上，那是游泳比赛的起点，海浪看起来非常可怕，我感到非常非常害怕。扩音器里的那个人说：“你无法控制海浪，你只能控制你对海浪的感觉。”那真是一个醍醐灌顶的时刻，我心想：“啊，如果我能运用我的大脑，我在运动方面可能会表现得更好。”因为我在学校时一直是个书呆子，总是最后一个离开更衣室去参加体育活动。我突然意识到，如果我能多动动脑子，我在运动上可以表现得更好。我跳进水里完成了游泳，那是我有史以来最快的一次铁人三项比赛，我想我以后可能不会再参加了。当我回到英国后，我真的
started looking into sports psychology and I think at the time there was probably only Steve Peter's book around the chimp paradox and there wasn't really that much else and there wasn't really much information on how to get into it but I wasn't enjoying my job at all and I had the ability to go and my husband said we'll just have a year off have a gap year and I was like yeah yeah I'll do that so I quit the job and and within two weeks I was bored. So I went to do a master's in psychology, a conversion course. And with the idea being that, well, that would always help understanding behaviour change. If you understand behaviour better, that's going to help me understand behaviour change. I can go straight back into communications. It will be helpful.
开始研究运动心理学。我想当时市面上可能只有 Steve Peters 的《黑猩猩悖论》这本书，除此之外并没有太多其他资料，也没有太多关于如何进入这个领域的资讯。但我当时一点也不喜欢我的工作，我有机会离开，我丈夫说：“我们就休息一年，过个间隔年吧。”我说：“好啊，我就这么做。”于是我辞职了，结果两周后我就感到无聊了。于是我去读了心理学硕士，这是一个转换课程。当时的想法是，这总能帮助我理解行为改变。如果你能更好地理解行为，那就能帮助我理解行为改变。我可以随时回到传播领域，这会有所帮助。
But with the idea that that maybe I could pick up the sports side too and I enjoyed that so I signed up for a master's in sport and exercise psychology it's usually a one-year course and then I discovered at the end of that if you actually want to be a sport and exercise psychologist it's another three years training I'm not sure I would have gone into it if I'd have properly done my research up front um but I was already halfway down the route by then so you then find a supervisor and you sign up to the BPS to do kind of it's not really a training course um it's more like you are out working as a trainee sports psychologist, but you have lots of boxes to tick. You have many, many, many hours to show of the work that you've been doing.
但当时也想着，也许我能顺便涉足运动领域。我对此很感兴趣，于是我报名参加了运动与锻炼心理学的硕士课程，通常是一年的课程。后来我发现，如果你真的想成为一名运动与锻炼心理学家，还需要再进行三年的培训。如果我当时做了充分的调研，我不确定我是否还会选择这条路，但那时我已经走了一半了。你需要找一位导师，并向英国心理学会（BPS）注册。这其实不是一个培训课程，更像是你作为一名实习运动心理学家在工作，但你需要完成很多考核指标。你需要展示你所做工作的很多很多小时的记录。
You have case studies to write. You do a large research project that's the equivalent of a PhD level research project. And that takes most people around three years to do okay so unlike clinical psychology for example there's not the machine that's having a forward momentum as well and kind of keeping you on track it sounds like it's very much just driven by yourself totally so there are three routes you can take now which has opened up since i did mine when i did it it was purely what we call bps stage two it's called the q-step um there is another route that's through basis which is often for people who've got more of a sport and exercise background rather than a psychology background i don't know that much about it but it feels like that one has much
你需要撰写案例研究。你还要完成一个大型研究项目，相当于博士水平的研究项目。大多数人需要大约三年时间才能完成。好的，所以与临床心理学不同，没有一个像机器一样向前推进的机制来让你保持进度，听起来这完全是靠你自己驱动的？完全是这样。现在有三条路线可以选择，这在我当年之后才开放。我当时走的是纯粹的 BPS 第二阶段，称为 Q-Step。还有另一条通过 BASES 的路线，通常适合那些有运动和锻炼背景而非心理学背景的人。我对此了解不多，但感觉那条路线有
more hand-holding so there are workshops that you go to as part of it. I don't think you have to do the research project, but a lot of it will be very similar. It's about building up hours of workshops and one to one work and communicating and explaining sports psychology processes. And there is also another route that you can do called a professional doctorate and there's three universities where you would do a doctorate but much more of a practical doctorate than you might otherwise do and you do that training alongside it so that so there's now three routes um but if you've got a psychology background you're probably most likely to go through the bps route but but it's
更多的指导。作为课程的一部分，你需要参加工作坊。我不认为你必须做研究项目，但很多内容会非常相似。它关乎积累工作坊和一对一工作的时长，以及沟通和解释运动心理学的过程。还有另一条路线叫做专业博士学位，有三所大学提供这种博士学位，它比你想象的要更注重实践，你会在培训的同时进行这些训练。所以现在有三条路线。但如果你有心理学背景，你很可能会选择 BPS 路线。但
not i was explaining to a trainee i was talking to you today it's not about following a curriculum and there's no classes to go to in any way and there's no structure you create it so to me it feels incredibly difficult however when you come out the other side, you are in an amazing position to be able to do what you need to do. So it forces you to stand on your own two feet. And it forces you to make it work, if it works. So if you make it through the process, you will be hopefully a really good sports psychologist. Because you've practiced what you've preached, I guess. But it feels like there is a niche in the market for someone having a more taught approach and a more formulaic approach that A plus B equals C plus D, you know, and that you come out at the end.
这并不是——我今天在向一位实习生解释时说，这并不是遵循一个课程大纲，没有任何课程可以去上，也没有任何结构，一切都需要你自己创造。所以对我来说，这感觉极其困难。然而，当你走出来时，你已经处于一个绝佳的位置，能够做你需要做的事情。它迫使你独立自主，迫使你让事情运转起来。所以，如果你能熬过这个过程，希望你会成为一名非常优秀的运动心理学家。因为我想，你实践了你所宣扬的。但感觉市场上确实存在一个利基市场，需要一种更具教学性、更公式化的方法，即 A 加 B 等于 C 加 D，最后能顺利毕业。
Or do you not feel, do you feel like this is part and parcel of becoming the sport and exercise psychologist I actually think it is that part and parcel bit so when I was going through it I was probably very critical about it and I can absolutely understand trainees frustrations however this is not an easy career to have. There are not many jobs in sports psychology. I did actually write a blog post a few years ago trying to figure out how many roles there were. I would guess there's probably 100 employed roles as an applied sports psychologist. So there's maybe 20, 25 people that would work for, it's just changed its name, it used to be the English Institute of Sport, and I think they've
还是说你不觉得？你觉得这是成为运动与锻炼心理学家的必经之路吗？我实际上认为这就是必经之路。当我在经历这个过程时，我可能对此非常挑剔，我完全能理解实习生的挫败感。然而，这不是一个容易从事的职业。运动心理学领域的工作岗位并不多。几年前我确实写过一篇博客文章，试图弄清楚到底有多少个职位。我猜作为应用运动心理学家，大概只有 100 个受雇岗位。可能有 20 到 25 个人在——它刚刚改名了，以前叫英国体育学院（English Institute of Sport），我想他们现在
become UK based now. And they work in the national governing bodies. So you might then work for British athletics, and you would be the sports site for British athletics. So it's something like 20, 25 people there. Then you have people that work in, say, the main football clubs, premiership clubs, rugby clubs, cricket clubs. And then you might have some people that work for TAS, which is kind of a talented athlete scheme that goes on within universities. That's it for like having an employed job where that is all you do and someone pays your salary. Many others are working in universities, teaching sports psychology in some way, and they will see some athletes on the side.
已经变成了英国本土机构。他们在国家管理机构工作。所以你可能会为英国田径队工作，成为他们的运动心理学家。所以那里大约有 20 到 25 人。然后是那些在主要足球俱乐部、英超俱乐部、橄榄球俱乐部、板球俱乐部工作的人。还有一些人可能为 TAS 工作，这是一种在大学内开展的天才运动员计划。这就是所有能让你获得受雇工作、有人支付薪水的情况了。许多其他人则在大学里以某种方式教授运动心理学，他们会顺便看一些运动员。
And then the rest of us, there's three or four companies that take on sports psychologists. They do performance work, usually in corporate worlds, actually. So they'll often be working either in schools doing teaching or they'll work with big corporates, but they'll be coming from the sports angle. And the rest of us all run our own private practices. of people coming out of masters in sport and exercise psychology courses who need to decide can they handle the fact they might basically be running their own business where are they going to go out and look for that work from um so some may be very lucky and get into a paid role but i have to say the paid roles don't pay very much um i've seen some i've seen some roles in premiership clubs advertised at around 20 000 pounds a year for someone that's got seven years of training
剩下的我们，有三四家公司会聘用运动心理学家。他们通常在企业界做表现工作。所以他们经常在学校做教学，或者与大企业合作，但他们是从运动的角度切入的。而我们其余的人都经营着自己的私人诊所。很多从运动与锻炼心理学硕士课程毕业的人，需要决定他们是否能接受自己基本上是在经营一家企业，他们必须自己去寻找工作。所以有些人可能很幸运，能得到一份带薪工作，但我必须说，带薪工作的薪水并不高。我见过一些英超俱乐部的职位，年薪大约只有 2 万英镑，而应聘者却拥有七年的培训经历。
so and for someone that's got the potential to make them vast amounts of money amazing isn't it yep um and and their arguments are but someone will do it so we can get away with it um but if you want to make a decent living you are probably going to have to be in applied practice private practice on your own and i think that means actually the training is probably right for that because you are having to figure out how to make it work you are having to connect with others you are having to network and although it's then a really small sector and it feels like it should be very competitive most of the time it's incredibly friendly and we're all send referrals to each other so if there's something I can't do I've got many other people
对于一个有潜力为他们赚取巨额财富的人来说，这真是太惊人了。是的，他们的理由是“总会有人愿意做的，所以我们可以压低薪水”。但如果你想过上体面的生活，你可能必须从事应用实践，即自己开私人诊所。我认为这意味着这种培训方式可能确实适合这种情况，因为你必须自己想办法让它运转起来。你必须与他人建立联系，你必须进行社交。虽然这是一个非常小的行业，感觉应该竞争非常激烈，但大多数时候它非常友好，我们都会互相推荐客户。如果有什么我做不了的事情，我有很多其他人
I can send it on to there's certain groups I don't really work with anymore because I'm not going to be a great psychologist for a 12 year old footballer and basically their mum and they don't want to hear from their mum so there'll be other people that I send on to and people that refer into me and other psychologists that I'll make connections with and we'll do work together. And so it's really friendly and really helpful. But that networking in those contexts are really, really important. And so I think it's really important that actually the training reflects that. You need to go out and find clients. You need to work out how to market yourself.
可以推荐。有些群体我不再接触了，因为我不会成为一个 12 岁足球运动员的好心理学家，而且基本上他们的妈妈也不想听我的建议，所以会有其他人我可以推荐给他们。也会有人推荐给我，我会与其他心理学家建立联系，我们一起合作。所以这个圈子非常友好，非常有帮助。但这些背景下的社交真的非常非常重要。所以我认为培训能够反映这一点非常重要。你需要走出去寻找客户。你需要弄清楚如何推销自己。
You're not going to be given very unlikely a role. And when you train, the BPS often suggests that you can go into a placement to do your training. And yet when I've asked, I put a little poll out on Twitter and 3% of people had a placement. Everybody else was finding a way to do it on their own and so I think the training needs to reflect that absolutely and is is there is there a cohort at all or are you sort of being taken on
你不太可能直接被赋予一个职位。当你进行培训时，BPS 经常建议你可以去实习以完成培训。然而，当我询问时，我在 Twitter 上做了一个小调查，只有 3% 的人有实习机会。其他人都在自己想办法。所以我认为培训绝对需要反映这一点。那么，在一年或整个教学计划中，是否有同伴群体，还是说你是
individually throughout a year or throughout a you know throughout the talk program so bases has two cohorts a year i think so then you have more of that feeling that you're with other people and you you get to share that experience which i think is really helpful on the bps route you just sign up and register when you're ready to do so so you don't have that cohort in the same way. But some people might well share the supervisor. And certainly when I supervise people, I have a group where they talk and they engage and you start to build up those contacts. I have a peer supervision group that I'm on where there's 12 of us who've all been qualified about the same time.
单独被录取的？BASES 每年有两个批次，我想是这样。所以你会更有那种与其他人在一起的感觉，你可以分享那种经历，我认为这非常有帮助。在 BPS 路线中，你只是在准备好时报名注册，所以你没有那种同伴群体。但有些人可能会共享导师。当然，当我指导别人时，我有一个小组，他们可以在那里交谈和互动，你开始建立那些联系。我有一个同行督导小组，我们有 12 个人，都是在同一时间获得资质的。
And we will use that to find somebody else that might be able to help if there's a difficult situation going on or to be able to get research papers if you need them. So that's one of the other problems is that we're not within organisations most of the time. And when you do the training, you're not within a university doing the training. And yet all the evidence you put forward in order to qualify must be evidence based. And so you need the literature, but there is no way to get the literature. So finding these kind of ways around it and being in groups and working with other people really helps, helps you to find what you need sounds that's very stressful and frustrating yes very amazing i don't know how you've done it like
如果遇到困难的情况，我们会利用这个小组寻找能提供帮助的人，或者在需要时获取研究论文。这是另一个问题，因为我们大多数时候不在机构内部。当你进行培训时，你不是在大学里进行培训。然而，你为了获得资质所提交的所有证据都必须是基于证据的。所以你需要文献，但却没有渠道获取文献。因此，找到这些变通方法，加入小组并与他人合作，真的很有帮助，能帮你找到你需要的东西。听起来这非常令人压力巨大且沮丧。是的，非常令人沮丧。太不可思议了，我不知道你是怎么做到的。
hats off to you hats off to you and you said there that you know with the bps route that you sort of apply when you're ready that makes it sound like anybody can do it but I'm sure that's not the case at all what are the essential or minimum requirements so you need to have is it a graduate basis for BPS membership and you have to have stage one and stage one is a master's in sport and exercise psychology that is accredited then you also need an enhanced DBS check and you need to know that you or show that you've got insurance. And then you need two references from qualified sports psychologists. So it does take quite a lot of information to pull together. And alongside that, you also need to write your own plan of work and that is a significant piece of work to figure out how are you going to do 2 000 hours of one-to-one work how are you going to do 2 000 hours
向你致敬，向你致敬。你刚才提到 BPS 路线是“准备好时申请”，这听起来好像任何人都能做，但我肯定事实并非如此。基本或最低要求是什么？你需要拥有 BPS 会员的毕业生基础资格（GBC），并且必须完成第一阶段，第一阶段是一个获得认证的运动与锻炼心理学硕士学位。然后你还需要一份增强型无犯罪记录证明（DBS），并且需要证明你拥有保险。此外，还需要两名合格运动心理学家的推荐信。所以确实需要收集很多信息。与此同时，你还需要编写自己的工作计划，这是一项重大的工作，要弄清楚你将如何完成 2000 小时的一对一工作，你将如何完成 2000 小时的
of research how it's about 400 hours i think of dissemination of cpd of ethics work um but it it's chunky at the time to do but it's really helpful for thinking about how do I go out and get what I need and how do I try and make some money at the same time yeah and actually that's I think it makes it more formulaic and it makes you know which you know which hoops you need to jump through and I guess for anyone in any area of psychology it might be helpful to think about that you know so even if they're working for example in an assistant psychologist route and they haven't got time for research well actually if you committed to yourself to think well I've got to do 100 hours this year of research-based
研究，还有大约 400 小时的传播、CPD（持续专业发展）和道德工作。这在当时看来很繁重，但对于思考“我如何走出去获得我需要的东西，以及如何同时尝试赚点钱”非常有帮助。是的，实际上我认为这让它变得更公式化了，让你知道你需要跨越哪些障碍。我想对于心理学任何领域的任何人来说，思考这个问题可能都会有所帮助。所以即使他们是在做助理心理学家的工作，没有时间做研究，但如果你承诺自己“我今年必须完成 100 小时的研究基础工作”，
stuff how are you going to do that? That's a really interesting and potentially useful idea. Yeah, and I would really advise anyone starting this process, when you think about the research bit, because it's so substantial, and I certainly felt like I was sulking a bit while I did a lot of it because I already had a PhD PhD and I was then being made to do 2000 hours of research when I've already got a higher qualification. I was definitely not in a great place about doing it. But if you can think about what you would like your specialism to be, that's really helpful. So I think it's really important when you're looking at the hours you do
你该怎么做？这是一个非常有趣且潜在有用的想法。是的，我真的建议任何开始这个过程的人，在考虑研究部分时，因为它太重要了。我做很多研究时确实感到有点闷闷不乐，因为我已经有了博士学位，却还要被迫完成 2000 小时的研究，这让我感觉不太好。但如果你能思考一下你希望你的专业方向是什么，那会非常有帮助。所以我认为当你查看你所做的培训时长时，获得一个非常好的范围非常重要。有些运动我不太喜欢参与，有些群体我可能表现不出色，但你需要知道这一点。所以你需要接触各种年龄段、男女、所有不同运动的群体。我想我现在已经参与过 27 种运动了，这对于之后决定“我到底喜欢哪些，哪些是好的，哪些适合我的工作方式”非常有帮助。真正理解所有这些，当你做了一点之后，就能说“我想我可能想专攻这个领域”。所以如果我必须做一个研究项目，我要让它成为
training you get a really good range so there's certain sports I don't particularly like working in there's certain groups that I'm not going to be brilliant with but you need to know that so you need to get a really wide range of age groups of both sexes of all the different sports I think I've worked in 27 sports now and that's really helpful for then going which ones do I actually like which ones are good which ones suit the way that I work um really understanding all of that but when you've done a little bit of that to then be able to go I think I might want to specialize in this area so if I've got to do a research project I'm going to make it something
有价值的东西。如果你能把它做成某种最终成为你的产品，或者让你脱颖而出的东西，那是非常有益的。我当时的研究课题是运动成瘾和技术，以及你使用技术越多，是否会影响你在超级马拉松运动员中产生运动成瘾的风险。我今天仍然使用很多我当时学到的东西，这对我将其作为我的专业方向非常有帮助。所以回顾过去，我认为这非常有帮助。只是在当时很令人沮丧，但深入研究一个可能塑造你整体实践的主题是完全值得的。谢谢。是的。而且事后看来，我可能也会为我的研究选择一个与我最终选择不同的领域，因为我当时的研究是在身体健康方面，而这实际上可能根本不是我工作的领域。但我认为，因为我在获得博士学位之前的许多研究生
that's worthwhile and if you can make it in something that almost ends up as a product for you or the thing that makes you stand out that's really beneficial so I did mine in exercise addiction and technology and whether the use the more you use technology whether it influences your risk of exercise addiction in ultra athletes and I still use a lot of what I learned today and it has been incredibly helpful for making that a specialism of mine so on reflection I think it is very helpful. It's just frustrating at the time, but it's totally worth really diving in depth to a subject that might well shape your practice overall. Thank you. Yeah. And I think with hindsight, I might well have picked a different area for my research than I ultimately did, because mine was in physical health and actually that's probably not an area that I work in at all but I think because a lot of my postgraduate
经历都是关于身体健康的，所以那是我当时的兴趣所在，但到我完成时，那肯定已经不是我的兴趣了。听到你谈论辅助技术，我在媒体上工作并写过关于“健康食品痴迷症”（orthorexia）的文章，即你强迫自己去跨越不同的里程碑。你可能会使用健身技术来让自己保持快乐，并感觉自己已经达到或实现了目标。我有一个 Fitbit。它藏在这个东西下面，因为我最近摔断了胳膊。即使是查看我走了多少步也很棘手，因为我无法转动我的胳膊。但我不知道你是否知道，最近 Fitbit 取消了所有的挑战。
experiences before I got onto the doctorate were physical health that sort of that was my interest at the time but it certainly wasn't my interest by the time I finished. Hearing you talk about assisted tech I work and have written in the media about orthorexia which is where you you're using, you know, you're forcing yourself to jump through different milestones. And you might be using fitness tech to kind of keep yourself happy and feel like you've attained or achieved. I have a Fitbit. It's hidden under this thing because I've broken my arm at the moment. And even being able to look at how many steps I've done is tricky because I can't twist my arm. But I don't know if you know, but recently Fitbit did away with all of their challenges.
所以 Fitbit Bingo 现在被取消了。Workweek Hustle，你也不能再与人竞争了。对我来说，那是 Fitbit 的主要吸引力之一。所以老实说，我在考虑把它扔掉。你知道，但即使在我的一些心理学同事和同学中，也存在这种竞争精神，试图比对方走得更多。但健康食品痴迷症和健身技术可能会变得比这更成问题，不是吗？这是一个非常棘手的领域，整个关于任何饮食失调和过度运动的要素，因为可能对于 70% 的人口来说，
So Fitbit Bingo is now scrapped. And Workweek Hustle, you can no longer compete against people. And for me, that was one of the main appeals of Fitbit. So I'm thinking about getting rid of it, to be honest. You know, but there's this competitive ethos, even within wearing, you know, me and some of my psychology colleagues and friends I went to school with, you know, trying to be a bit steppier than the other. But orthorexia and fit tech can become more problematic than that, can't it? It's a really tricky area and the whole area around any elements of disordered eating and over exercising, because probably. For 70 percent of the population.
确实需要吃得更健康、多运动，并且已经出台了一些支持这一点的政策要素，比如菜单上的卡路里标注。有研究表明，对于那些容易暴饮暴食的人来说，这非常有帮助。我当然知道我会看，并且会根据我看到的内容做出不同的选择。所以对于那群人来说，菜单上的卡路里是有帮助的，有助于决策和助推过程。但对于那些患有饮食失调症的人来说，它们真的非常非常危险。这绝对是一个让你回到饮食失调心态的诱因，你脑海中那个饮食失调的声音会利用卡路里来彻底击垮你，那是一个可怕的境地。同样，通过手机或 Fitbit 获取的所有信息，
Need to probably eat healthier and move more and there are some policy elements that have been put in place that support that so calories on menus there is research that shows for those who are likely to be overeating that is incredibly helpful and I certainly know I will look and I will make different choices based on what I see. So for that group of people, calories on a menu are helpful and help with that decision making the nudge process. For those who've had an eating disorder, they are really, really dangerous. It is an absolute prompt to get you back into that eating disorder mindset and that that eating disorder voice in your head will use the calories it seems totally totally beat you up and it's a horrible place to be similarly with all the information
对某些人来说，比别人多走几步、获得反馈真的很好，非常有帮助；但对其他人来说却非常危险。所以在使用什么和谁在使用之间存在这种真正的不匹配。我经常建议我的运动员不要使用 Strava 之类的东西，因为——我在做那项研究时真的发现了这一点——我采用一种叫做 ACT（接纳承诺疗法）的方法。我喜欢其中的一个要素是“价值观”，它能帮助你弄清楚什么对你真正重要，而不是那些容易衡量的事情。我们的手表永远不会告诉我们什么才是真正重要的。我们的手表只会告诉我们什么容易衡量。所以我们最终会根据手表上的一些测量数据来验证自己、证明自己，并思考自己是一个好人还是坏人，
you can get off your phone or your fitbit for some people to be a bit steppier than the others really good to get the feedback can be very helpful for others really dangerous and so there is this real mismatch between who uses what and I will often advise my athletes not to use things like Strava because and I've really found this when I did that research that I work from an approach called ACT acceptance and commitment theory and one of the elements I love in it is values it helps you work out what actually matters to you not the things that are just easy to measure. And our watch is never going to tell us what actually matters. Our watch will tell us what's easy to measure. And so we end up validating ourselves and justifying and thinking whether we're a good or bad person
而不是思考：我享受那次跑步吗？我是否和那个一直很痛苦、现在因为我们一起跑步而感觉好多了的朋友叙旧了？所以我经常要求运动员进行“裸奔”练习，不带任何技术设备。他们可以穿衣服，但我希望他们不带任何技术设备做运动。我真的希望他们思考：他们是如何激励自己的？当它与时间、距离甚至进了多少球无关时，他们是如何享受它的？我倾向于与一群非常特定的运动员合作，他们都有表现焦虑。他们都有两个共同点：他们非常聪明，而且是完美主义者。我称他们为 VIP。那种完美主义因素意味着他们不断地试图打败他们的手表或在 Strava 上打败他们的朋友，这变成了一个非常大的、你知道的，用来
based on some measurements on our watch. Not, did I enjoy that run? did I catch up with my friend who's been really miserable and now feels a lot better because we went for a run together and so I'll often ask athletes to to go for naked exercise um with no tech they're allowed to wear their clothes um but I want them to do stuff with no tech I really want them to think about how do they motivate themselves? How do they enjoy it when it's not to do with what times or distance or even how many goals they've scored? And I do tend to work with a very specific group of athletes who all have performance anxiety. And they all have two traits in common. They're very intelligent and they're perfectionistic I call them VIPs and that perfectionism element means they're constantly trying to beat their watch or beat their friend on Strava and it just becomes a really big you know hammer to beat
击垮自己的锤子，而不是记住“我为什么做这个？我做这个是因为我享受它，我做这个是因为我想感觉健康”。周三晚上我在一所学校做了一个工作坊，我们谈论了动力。这太可爱了，因为我们都在填写便利贴，把它们贴得到处都是，写着不同的动力要素。他们只是说：“我喜欢我获得新技能时的感觉，我喜欢我努力工作一小时后的感觉。”他们提出的任何东西都不是“我喜欢知道我每天完成了 10,000 步”。所以我完全明白为什么挑战、卡路里和所有其他东西对某些人有帮助，但对于那些已经勤奋且致力于运动和锻炼的人来说，
themselves up with rather than remembering why do I do this I do it because I enjoy it I do it because I I want to feel fit and healthy I did a workshop with um a school on Wednesday night and we talked about motivation it was so lovely because we're all filling in post-it notes and sticking them all over the place of different elements of motivation and um they were just like I just love how I feel when I achieve a new skill I love how I feel when I've worked really hard for an hour nothing that they came up with was I like knowing I've done my 10,000 steps a day um so I can absolutely see why challenges and calories and all that other stuff can be helpful for some people but for people that are already diligent and dedicated to their sport and exercise
它们可能具有极大的破坏性，它们会剥夺他们所做事情的所有乐趣。我没有答案，因为我不知道你如何阻止某些人看到这些东西。但我认为，人们拥有“我正在做这个，这对我有帮助吗？”的自我意识是非常有帮助的。是的，我完全听到了。你提出的观点非常令人难以置信，富有洞察力和深思熟虑。有趣的是，当我听你说话并反思时，最初我刚开始进行重量训练时，我会在事后告诉我的手表我已经完成了。我想：“太棒了，45 分钟的锻炼，做得真聪明。”但随着时间的推移，因为操作起来很麻烦，
they can be incredibly harmful and they can rip all the joy out of what they do and I don't have an answer because yeah I don't know how you you block some people from seeing things but I think it's really helpful for people to have the self-awareness of I am doing this is it helpful for me yeah I hear you absolutely it's really incredible and insightful thoughtful points that you've raised there and it's interesting when when I was listening to you and reflecting that initially when I first started going weight training, I would tell my watch afterwards that I'd done it. I'm like, amazing, 45 minutes exercise, cleverly well done. But over time, because it was fiddly to do and a faff,
而且我的手表没有自动识别那是锻炼，因为它不够“硬核”。我就懒得做了。但我从未感到困扰。但我仍然喜欢做它。你知道，我喜欢与我的私人教练建立联系。好吧，当我能再次举重时，我会喜欢做它的。但是，我获得的收益远比我从 Fitbit 认为那会很酷的想法中获得的要多得多。是的。几年前我做过一个实验，我为《Cycling Weekly》写一些专题文章，Garmin 给了我他们最好的型号，我按照他们的训练计划训练了一个月。
and my watch didn't automatically recognize that as exercise because it wasn't, you know, hardcore enough. I just didn't bother doing it, but because it wasn't, you know, hardcore enough. I just didn't bother doing it. But I never bothered. But I still loved doing it. You know, I loved connecting with my personal trainer. Well, I'm going to love doing it when I can lift weights again. But, you know, I was gaining so much more than I ever would have gained from my Fitbit thinking that would have been quite cool. Yeah. I did an experiment a couple of years ago for, I write some features for Cycling Weekly and Garmin gave me their very best model and I followed their training for a month.
然后我按照我教练的训练计划训练了一个月。实际上非常有趣的是，它们非常相似。即使我跟着手表训练，我仍然会得到我教练的训练计划。有时它们是完全一样的。但我从拥有教练那里得到了更多。我得到了那种联系。我得到了反馈。我得到了交流。我得到了理解，即我那周工作非常辛苦，事情非常多，周日去跑两小时根本没有意义，因为我的身体根本无法承受那种训练，它会产生抵触，而且很可能我
And then I followed my coach's training for a month. And actually what was really interesting was it was very similar. And I would still get my coaches training even when I'm following the watch. And some days they would be identical. But I got so much more from having a coach. I got that connection. I got the feedback. I got the chatting through things. I got the understanding that I was having a really tough week work-wise and I had so much going on and there was no point me going out to do a two-hour run on the Sunday because my body just wouldn't be able to take in that training it was going to push against and very likely I would
可能会受伤或生病。所以从一个人那里得到的，远比手表喂给你的东西要多得多。确实如此。有时我合作的一些客户，例如那些可能还在全日制教育中，享受运动，并期待未来成为成功运动员的人，非常不愿意接受任何形式的学术辅导，因为他们认为那是作弊。但他们却能接受运动员会有教练的事实，却无法觉得在学业上获得一点额外帮助是可以的。人们该如何看待这个问题？我想，我只见到那些来找我的人，他们是为了表现教练而来。我有很多家长
probably get injured or ill and so there is so much more you can get from a person than you are going to get from a watch feeding you things there is for sure and sometimes some of the clients I work with um who might still be in full-time education for example um and enjoying exercise um and looking ahead to you know successful athletes are really reluctant to have any sort of academic coaching because they see that as cheating but yet can get on board with the fact that athletes would have um you know coaches but they can't feel that that's okay for them to almost get a bit of extra help with their academia how could people think around that i guess i i only see the people that come to me um and they're coming for performance coaching and I get a lot of parents
会说：“你能和我的孩子一起做运动方面的辅导吗？你能顺便加入一些关于考试压力的内容吗？”我知道下个月我合作的每一个 18 岁以下的孩子，我们都不会在运动方面做太多，我们会在考试方面做。但技巧是完全一样的。所以我对运动员、参加考试的人，或者即将进行非常非常棘手手术的高级眼科医生使用的技巧，它们是完全一样的。有很多关于心理教育的工作，理解为什么你的大脑有时会给你一些非常无益的对话。然后致力于如何改变你脑海中的那些对话。
that will be saying can you work with my child on their sports can you sneak in some stuff around exam stress and I know the next month every under 18 that I work with we won't really be doing much on the sports side we will be doing it on the exam side. But the techniques are identical. So the technique I would use with an athlete, or someone going through exams, or a senior eye surgeon trying to do a really, really tricky operation that's coming up, they're identical. There's lots of work around psychoeducation, understanding why your brain is sometimes giving you really unhelpful conversations going on. And then working on how do you change those conversations in your head.
我们会关注很多关于能够更好地自我辩护的内容，大量你使用的自我对话，大量的价值观，以及为什么你可能会有那些恐惧或焦虑，但无论如何你都会按照你的价值观行事。然后我们会建立像心理技能这样的东西。所以我认为我会和那些即将参加考试的运动员做很多工作，比如控制映射：你现在能控制什么？你能把注意力放在什么上面？你不能控制什么？以及你如何接受你无法控制它并能够继续前进？或者像“如果……怎么办”的计划，把你担心的每一件可能发生的事情都列出来，尤其是那些愚蠢的事情。人们会说：“我知道这听起来很傻，但这就是我们想要的。”
We'll be looking a lot at being able to self-advocate better lots of the self-talk that you're using lots of the values and why you might have those fears or those anxieties but you're going to work in line with your values anyway and then we'll build things like mental skills in so i think i'll do a lot with with those athletes that've got exams coming up might be something like control mapping what can you control right now and what focus can you put on that what can't you control and how do you accept that you can't control it and be able to move on or things like what if planning every single thing you were worried about that's that could happen and and especially the silly things people go there's always a I know this sounds silly but it's like that's what we want on there um and then we put the well how are you going to prevent that happening what can you do in the next
然后我们制定“你将如何防止这种情况发生？你在接下来的几周里能做些什么，意味着这种情况发生的可能性会降低？”但你知道，有些事情可能会发生，因为它们确实会发生，这就是生活。在那个时刻你打算做什么？这样，你的威胁系统就不会启动，你也不会无法进行逻辑、理性的思考，你能够保持你想要的思维。我会把这完全同样地用于这个周末第一次参加铁人三项、担心在公开水域游泳时水下可能有什么东西的人，用于那些
few weeks that means that's less likely to happen but you know what stuff might happen because it does and that's life and what are you going to do in that moment so that instead of your threat system kicking in and you not being able to think logically, rationally, that you are able to keep that thinking that you want. And I would use that exactly the same for someone who's got their first triathlon this weekend and is worried about what might be in the water below them when they're in open water swimming, through to someone that's got an exam
不确定自己是否进行了正确训练的考试的人，以及即将迎来首演之夜的歌剧演员。你会使用完全相同的技巧。它只是与某人所处的环境背景相匹配。而且这不是作弊。这是优化，你知道，是在帮自己一个忙。我的意思是，运动员练习的量。所以我经常与游泳运动员合作，他们大多数人每周在泳池里待大约 15 个小时。我无法理解为什么你会每周在游泳池里待 15 个小时——我讨厌游泳——然后不花一小时进行一些心理技能练习，或者真正计划当你的比赛中发生某些事情时你将如何表现，或者为那场比赛做好充分准备。
that they're not sure they've done the right training through, through to an opera singer that's got their first night coming up. You'd have exactly the same techniques. It's just matched to the context of the environment that somebody's in. And it's not cheating. It's optimising and, you know, doing yourself a favour. I mean, the amount of practice that athletes do. So I work a lot with swimmers most of them are in the pool for like 15 hours a week I cannot understand why you would spend 15 hours a week in a swimming pool I hate swimming um and then not spend an hour a week doing some mental skills practice or really planning how you're going to behave when something happens in your race or to prep for that race fully.
他们不确定自己是否接受了正确的训练，一直到即将迎来首演的歌剧演员。你们用的技巧完全一样，只是根据所处的环境进行了调整。这并不是作弊，而是在优化，是在帮自己一把。我的意思是，运动员们进行了大量的练习。我经常和游泳运动员合作，他们大多数人每周在泳池里待上15个小时左右，我无法理解为什么你会花每周15个小时在游泳池里——我讨厌游泳——却不花一个小时进行心理技能练习，或者真正规划好当比赛中发生突发状况时你该如何应对，又或者为那场比赛做好充分的准备。
It's like the brain side needs regular, regular practice, but it's a tiny amount compared to the amount of physical activity that we tend to do. Absolutely. Just before we come on to discuss your amazing book that I'm listening to at the moment, I wanted to talk to you a little bit about amenorrhea. I don't even know if I've said that right. I think I might have done, which is where your periods stop. And in sports people, it's potentially quite common because of the amount of exercise they're doing, the amount of calorie deficit and all of that jazz. But what I get when I work with people who have that presentation
这就像大脑方面需要经常性的练习，但与我们通常进行的体力活动量相比，这只是微不足道的一点点。绝对是这样。在我们讨论你那本我目前正在听的精彩著作之前，我想和你聊聊闭经。我甚至不知道我有没有说对。我想我可能说对了，就是指月经停止。在运动员中，由于他们进行的运动量、热量缺口以及所有这些因素，这种情况可能相当普遍。但是，当我与有这种表现的人合作时，我得到的情况是
as a result of eating disorders is that they'll say well it's okay for professional sport people so why is it not okay for me and I'd really love your view on that please Josie. So it is not okay for professional sports people it's, really harmful to their performance. Two, they will end up with stress fractures long term and they'll plateau and they'll just get burnout. So they won't actually be able to improve anyway. Are the stress fractures linked to bone density and oestrogen and calcium and all of that jazz
由于饮食失调导致的结果，他们会说，好吧，这对职业运动员来说没问题，那为什么对我来说就不行呢？我真的很想听听你的看法，Josie。所以，这对职业运动员来说也是不行的，这对他们的表现真的很有害。第一，他们最终会长期出现应力性骨折，表现会进入平台期，并且会精疲力竭。所以他们实际上根本无法提高。应力性骨折与骨密度、雌激素、钙以及所有这些因素有关吗？
yeah for male and females um and then third it screws up your fertility long term so there are many elite athletes who have had to go through IVF for to have their children um and many who amateurs and elites who haven't been able to have children. So it was almost seen a while ago, hopefully a while ago, as a badge of honour. You have trained hard enough that you don't get a period. So it was seen as like a, wow, that makes you almost elite. And certainly 10, 15 years ago, when I first started learning about it, it was definitely that kind of look at me. I'm good enough. I don't get a period. We now know how harmful that is for you, for performance and long term health. It tends to be known as RED-S. So it stands for relative energy deficiency in sport.
是的，对男性和女性都是如此。第三，它会长期破坏你的生育能力。所以有很多精英运动员不得不通过试管婴儿来生孩子，还有许多业余选手和精英选手无法生育。所以前几年，希望是前几年，这几乎被视为一种荣誉勋章。你训练得足够刻苦，以至于月经停止了。所以这被视为一种，哇，这让你几乎成了精英。当然，10到15年前，当我第一次了解它时，它绝对是那种“看看我，我足够优秀，我没有月经”的样子。我们现在知道这对你、对表现和长期健康有多大的危害。它通常被称为RED-S，即运动相对能量不足。
And it's often thought of as an accidental eating disorder. So you are not actively trying to lose weight to change your body shape. What most people do is they step up the amount of exercise that they do without matching that with the amount of calories that they need. And so it is often accidental, but sometimes it will be. There are still some sports, particularly cycling, running, climbing, where there is this whole culture that lighter is faster. And so people will try and drop some weight to get faster. And the real problem with it is that that works for a short amount of time. So you've still got the strength you've built up, but very quickly,
它通常被认为是一种意外的饮食失调。所以你并不是主动试图减肥来改变体型。大多数人所做的是增加了运动量，却没有与他们所需的热量相匹配。所以它通常是意外的，但有时也会是故意的。仍然有一些运动，特别是自行车、跑步、攀岩，存在着“越轻越快”的文化。所以人们会试图减轻一些体重来跑得更快。而它真正的问题在于，这在短时间内是有效的。所以你仍然拥有你建立起来的力量，但很快，
you lose some weight, and you are then able to go faster using that strength. And then you break. So for women, it will be that your period stops. For men, it will be they don't get a morning erection, because their testosterone levels have dropped so much. And then over time, when that continues, you start to struggle with energy levels and the big thing that normally stops people in their tracks is stress fractures particularly runners because you are not giving your body the hormones that it needs you are starving yourself in a way and then you are running up and down on bones that are getting very, very damaged. So that's unhelpful for particularly an elite level because you cannot progress.
你减轻了一些体重，然后你就能利用那股力量跑得更快。然后你就崩溃了。对于女性来说，就是月经停止。对于男性来说，就是他们早上没有晨勃，因为他们的睾酮水平下降得太多了。随着时间的推移，当这种情况持续下去，你开始在能量水平上挣扎，而通常让人们停下脚步的大事是应力性骨折，特别是跑步者，因为你没有给身体提供它所需的激素，你在某种程度上是在挨饿，然后你在受到严重损伤的骨骼上跑来跑去。所以这对精英水平来说是无益的，因为你无法进步。
You will then be out for a while. And it's horrible, but I love the fact that quite a few elite runners have been talking about this. And they will explain to people that they have had red S and why it is so dangerous. And others celebrate getting their periods back um i've had little period parties with clients where we're like high-fiving at the screen because they've got their first period in a few years it feels really odd but it's so important um and it's about then changing the culture in elite sport that we have to talk about this stuff and I will talk about it with male coaches when I'm working with an athlete and I talk to their coach and I'm like do you know whether they get their period and they'll be like oh can't ask a girl that
然后你会休息一段时间。这很糟糕，但我喜欢这样一个事实，即相当多的精英跑步者一直在谈论这个问题。他们会向人们解释他们患有RED-S以及为什么它如此危险。其他人则庆祝他们月经恢复。我和客户举行过小型的“月经派对”，我们在屏幕前击掌，因为他们几年来第一次来了月经。这感觉真的很奇怪，但它非常重要。这是关于改变精英体育中的文化，我们需要谈论这些事情。当我与运动员合作时，我会和男教练谈论它，我问他们的教练，你知道她们是否来月经吗？他们会说，哦，不能问女孩那个问题。
you're like how do you know if she's healthy enough then to do this training that you're setting we have to make it much more normal to be able to talk about those health markers so that we can make sure somebody is in the best place to do it um and and we will we don't really want someone training particularly hard we'll cap what training somebody's doing at quite a low heart rate until they've had three periods back and so it's it's not just about stepping up the eating it can be probably a six to twelve month process of getting healthy again so for elites that's a year out of their career we absolutely don't want them getting into that state um but for for regular amateurs too that takes so much joy away from what you do and it the big thing is it tends to curtail your social life because many of us get into our sport and then we join a club and that's how we get lots
你会想，那你怎么知道她是否足够健康来完成你设定的训练呢？我们必须让谈论这些健康指标变得更加正常，这样我们才能确保某人处于最佳状态来完成训练。我们真的不希望有人进行特别艰苦的训练，我们会将某人的训练心率限制在很低的水平，直到她们恢复三次月经。所以这不仅仅是增加饮食，这可能是一个长达6到12个月的恢复健康的过程。对于精英选手来说，这意味着职业生涯中有一年时间。我们绝对不希望他们陷入那种状态。但对于普通业余爱好者来说，这也从你所做的事情中夺走了很多乐趣。最重要的一点是，它往往会限制你的社交生活，因为我们许多人进入运动领域，然后加入俱乐部，这就是我们获得很多
of our excitement and we go on training camps together and then suddenly your sense of belonging goes because you don't feel like you belong to that group. It's really harsh. So I think we need to talk about it much, much more. And if you've got clients who are saying, oh, but elites are allowed to do this, they're not. And more and more is being put in place to stop that. Great. Thank you so much for eliminating that for myself and for our audience as well.
兴奋感的方式，我们一起去训练营，然后突然间你的归属感就消失了，因为你不觉得你属于那个群体。这真的很残酷。所以我认为我们需要更多地谈论它。如果你有客户说，哦，但精英选手被允许这样做，他们其实是不被允许的。而且越来越多的措施正在实施以阻止这种情况。太棒了。非常感谢你为我以及我们的听众消除了这些误解。
And it's really important stuff to hold on to that we're we're talking about with our clients so your most recent book baby I think it's your most recent is called the 10 pillars and I'm currently listening to it on audible and your voice is just amazing I'm loving it and you've got a little bit of music I can't listen to it oh I love the music bits they um that's the best part of writing an audible book is that when you've recorded everything they've got the most amazing database of every single piece of music you could ever imagine and you get to kind of go I really like piano and this and happiness and they'll type it in and then you just get thousands of pieces of music to pick from and choose and play it in the background it's like the most fun I've had in years it's really fun it's really fun
坚持谈论这些对我们的客户来说非常重要。所以你最近的书，我想是你最近的一本，叫《10大支柱》，我目前正在Audible上听，你的声音太棒了，我很喜欢。而且你还有一点音乐，我听不到，哦，我喜欢那些音乐片段。那是写有声书最棒的部分，当你录制完所有内容后，他们拥有你能想象到的每一段音乐的最棒数据库，你可以说我真的很喜欢钢琴，还有这个和快乐，他们会输入进去，然后你就会得到成千上万的音乐片段来挑选，并在背景中播放。这是我多年来做过的最有趣的事情，真的很有趣，真的很有趣。
and I think it's the only other audio book other than Will Smith's I don't know if you've ever listened to his on his audio book is amazing because he like raps in it he's got music in it he's got background and it's like it's such a good audio book to listen to. It is. It's also ghostwritten, I think, by Mark Manson, who has written. Oh, is it? I didn't realize it had been ghostwritten. I thought he'd just done it all himself rather well. No, no, no, no. He's written some fascinating psychology books, particularly around relationships, where, again, in his books, he's almost um it's kind of half podcast where he's interviewed and worked
而且我认为这是除了威尔·史密斯的那本之外，我听过的唯一一本有声书。我不知道你有没有听过他的，他的有声书太棒了，因为他在里面说唱，有音乐，有背景音，这真是一本非常好的有声书。确实是。我想它也是由马克·曼森代笔的，他写过……哦，是吗？我没意识到它是代笔的。我以为他自己写得很好。不，不，不，不。他写了一些引人入胜的心理学书籍，特别是关于人际关系的，在这些书中，它几乎是……它有点像半个播客，他采访并与
with clients about their their sexual their relationship kind of histories and backgrounds as he coaches them through and so I was listening to Will Smith's book loving it but going this is very well written by an actor I did think it was very well written. And then having seen the more recent, you know, goings on at the Oscars, I thought, oh, there's a slight mismatch here, maybe. Yeah. But I thought from a psychological perspective,
客户合作，了解他们的性关系、人际关系历史和背景，并在他指导他们的过程中进行交流。所以我当时在听威尔·史密斯的书，很喜欢，但心想，这作为一个演员写得太好了。我确实认为它写得很好。然后看到最近在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上发生的事情，我想，哦，这里可能有一点不匹配。是的。但我从心理学的角度来看，
he just got the psychology of things. And I was like listening to it going, there's so many lessons in here about mindset and behaviours and ways to go out and achieve great performance. And I think the ghostwriter really cleverly pulled those out because it was almost like I wanted to circle the audio book of going, oh, but this bit, this bit's brilliant. So Will's book's good, but yours is also very good. And one of the, I'm quite early on in it, but I am loving it. You interviewed Dame Kelly Holmes. And I think one of the bits that's particularly relevant for our current aspiring psychologist audience is when she's talking about individual pursuits, but also the importance of the team approach. And I know, I think there was
他抓住了事物的心理。我听着听着心想，这里面有太多关于心态、行为以及如何去实现伟大表现的课程。我认为代笔作家非常聪明地把这些提炼了出来，因为我几乎想圈出有声书的重点，心想，哦，这一段，这一段太精彩了。所以威尔的书很好，但你的书也非常好。而且，我才刚开始听，但我很喜欢。你采访了凯利·霍姆斯女爵。我认为其中一个对我们目前的心理学专业学生特别相关的部分是，当她谈论个人追求，但也谈论团队方法的重要性时。我知道，我想当时有
a quite high profile, it might have been gymnast who was booted off the team for being too self-focused. And she was like, but it's an individual sport. I don't know why it matters. But Dame Kelly is saying, well, it it does matter and actually the ability to think about others in your team and others in your industry not necessarily as competition but as an asset i really liked what you were saying about that could you illuminate us in that area yeah when it's a when i do my intro sessions with new clients i'll always ask who's on your team and most of my clients to be honest are individual sports and they're like I do an individual sport I'm like you know I know
一位相当引人注目的，可能是一位体操运动员，因为过于关注自我而被踢出了团队。她说，但这是一项个人运动。我不知道为什么这很重要。但凯利女爵说，嗯，它确实很重要，实际上，将团队中的其他人以及你行业中的其他人视为资产，而不是竞争对手，这种能力非常重要。我真的很喜欢你所说的关于这一点的内容，你能在这方面启发我们吗？是的，当我与新客户进行介绍性会议时，我总是会问谁在你的团队中。老实说，我的大多数客户都是个人运动项目，他们会说我从事的是个人运动。我说，我知道，
but who's on your team who's on your side who's got your back who are the people you go to when you're having a bad day when you need to ask something about training when something hurts when you're feeling sad and we'll really pull out kind of who is on their side so many of them will have a coach but it's like oh but I've got Fred at training and Fred always is a really good giggle and oh yeah I've got a physio I go and see if this thing's wrong and yeah there's a teacher at school who really seems to get me and we really pull out what are you part of um and I think that's really helpful and Kelly brought this home beautifully in a really sad section of the interview that I did with her where she talked
但谁在你的团队里？谁站在你这边？谁支持你？当你度过糟糕的一天时，当你需要询问关于训练的事情时，当某处受伤时，当你感到悲伤时，你会去找谁？我们真的会挖掘出谁站在他们那边。他们中的许多人会有教练，但他们会说，哦，我在训练时有弗雷德，弗雷德总是很有趣，哦，是的，如果有什么不对劲，我会去看理疗师，是的，学校里有一位老师真的很懂我。我们真的会挖掘出你是谁的一部分。我认为这非常有帮助。凯利在我对她进行的采访中，在一个非常悲伤的部分，很好地说明了这一点，她谈到了
about in 2004 she was training with an athlete from another country and her coach and the coach had both of them and she didn't feel like the coach had her back. She felt like this other athlete was the number one athlete and she was kind of slotting in. And she was really, really miserable. She was self-harming. And she said she had this realisation that I don't belong here and that's why I'm self-harming. That's why I'm trying to find a way to feel something. And she changed coach. She joined the the GB setup and she went out to training camps with the other GB athletes she said that was such a huge change for her so she had the GB physio
在2004年，她和来自另一个国家的运动员一起训练，教练同时指导他们两人，她觉得教练并不支持她。她觉得另一位运动员是头号运动员，而她只是被安排进去的。她非常非常痛苦。她在自残。她说她意识到我不属于这里，这就是我自残的原因。这就是我试图寻找一种感觉的原因。她换了教练。她加入了英国队的设置，并和其他英国运动员一起去训练营。她说这对她来说是一个巨大的改变。所以她有了英国队的理疗师，
that she was checking in with regularly she had a coach that was on her side and that was the year she won two Olympic gold medals and so I just thought that was there's so much more behind it but it's it's become her thing so when she was still training before she got her Olympic medals actually she created something called on camp with Kelly where she would take younger girls um kind of late teens and take them away to really understand it's not just about running a lot it is about the nutrition the hydration the looking after your body the strength and conditioning the having people on your side looking after each other and she really built that up and now she has lots of projects um that pretty much started during lockdown where she was doing exercises um in front of her alpacas that
她定期与理疗师沟通，她有一位支持她的教练，那一年她赢得了两枚奥运金牌。所以我只是觉得这背后还有很多东西，但这已经成为了她的标志。所以当她在获得奥运奖牌之前还在训练时，她实际上创建了一个名为“与凯利一起训练营”的项目，她会带一些年轻女孩，大约十几岁，带她们出去，真正理解这不仅仅是关于大量的跑步，而是关于营养、补水、照顾你的身体、力量和体能训练、有支持你的人、互相照顾。她真的建立起了这个项目，现在她有很多项目，
she has um to to draw people in but I've got friends that loved that because they were like we're all doing this together it's it really helped and you absolutely needed that lockdown especially if you're living on your own of like you've got that solitude that loneliness and yet for half an hour a day you get to check in with all these other people and you're on and they're a Facebook group where you're talking about things. And that connection is so powerful. I think that's really important. I absolutely agree. And one of the things that some of my members have said on the membership is, God, I didn't realise how important everybody else would be, that actually I would genuinely care about their success and I would
这些项目几乎是在封锁期间开始的，当时她在她的羊驼面前做运动，这些羊驼是她拥有的，用来吸引人们。但我有朋友喜欢那样，因为他们说我们都在一起做这件事，这真的很有帮助。你绝对需要那种封锁，特别是如果你独自生活，那种孤独感，但每天半小时，你可以和其他人交流，你们在Facebook群组里谈论事情。这种联系非常强大。我认为这非常重要。我完全同意。而且我的一些会员在会员群里说的一件事是，天哪，我没意识到其他人会如此重要，实际上我会真心关心他们的成功，我会
genuinely be concerned for them and you know moved when things don't work out for them and it's such an important part of any career but you know this psychology career which can feel quite individual it's you know it doesn't always need to feel that way and it shouldn't feel that way um i something i always talk about with athletes is that the latin meaning of the word competition is actually compietra which means striving together so competition isn't about being better than everybody else it's about using everybody around you to all be better and I think we can have such a different mindset when we think like that rather than it's me going up against 20 people for that role or me trying to show that I'm the best to do this
真正地关心他们，当事情进展不顺时也会感到难过，这是任何职业中非常重要的一部分。但心理学这个职业有时会让人感觉非常孤立，其实它并不总是需要这样，也不应该这样。我经常和运动员谈论的一点是，竞争（competition）一词的拉丁语词源是“compietra”，意思是“共同努力”。所以竞争不是为了比别人强，而是利用周围的人来共同进步。我认为当我们这样思考时，心态会大不相同，而不是想着我是在和20个人竞争这个职位，或者试图证明我是最棒的。
it's like if we all work together we can do so much cooler stuff. And similarly, I use the example of if you're on the start line for a big competition as a hundred metre sprinter and your goal is to win. And you look across and as you say, bolt, like no chance. What's the point? You've given up before you started. If you're on that start line and your goal is to get a PB, to be the best you can possibly be on that day, you look across and as you're saying, Bo, you're like, yes, I'm going to follow his heels. I am going to do, I'm just going to follow. And I get to be in this competition with the best guy in the world. This is going to be amazing. You have such a different mindset. You approach it differently. You will do better. And so, so much in sport, but other parts of
就像如果我们齐心协力，就能做出更酷的事情。同样，我举个例子，如果你是一名百米短跑运动员，站在大型比赛的起跑线上，你的目标是获胜。你环顾四周，看到了博尔特，心想“没机会了”，那还没开始你就已经放弃了。但如果你的目标是刷新个人最好成绩（PB），在当天发挥出最佳水平，你环顾四周，看到博尔特，你会想“太棒了，我要紧跟他的步伐”。我能和世界上最顶尖的选手同场竞技，这太不可思议了。你的心态会完全不同，处理方式也会不同，表现也会更好。所以，这不仅在体育界，在其他领域也是如此。
sectors too, are about winning and outcomes. And I am so focused on the more we try and win, the harder we make it for ourselves, because suddenly there's a ton of threat. And threat, as we know, changes our physiology and it changes our mindset if we focus on input what can I do what tasks can I do to the best of my ability we are more likely to do well and I think that applies just as much to us as psychologists and it's hard because I love Sunday afternoons because the athletes I work with will message me about how they've done in their competitions or I'll scroll through Instagram and I'll see that somebody got third at a world championships yes they've done it but it's actually then you also have to remind yourself that their results are not whether we have done a good or bad job
其他行业也是关于赢和结果的。我非常关注这一点：我们越是试图赢，就越是给自己增加难度，因为突然之间就充满了威胁感。正如我们所知，威胁会改变我们的生理状态和心态。如果我们专注于投入，专注于我能做些什么任务来发挥出最佳能力，我们更有可能做得好。我认为这对我们心理学家来说同样适用。这很难，因为我喜欢周日下午，因为我合作的运动员会给我发信息告诉他们比赛的情况，或者我刷Instagram看到有人在世锦赛上拿了第三名。是的，他们做到了，但你实际上也必须提醒自己，他们的结果并不代表我们做得好还是坏。
actually if somebody has to pull out of an ultra competition because their feet were in a total and utter mess because they important to to not be focused on that winning bit and even how our athletes do what accolades they get but it's like how have I helped that athlete yes be successful but be successful with their own values in a way that matters for them not again coming back to the what does a watch or a measure say and am I measuring my own success on them because that's steps and steps away from what we've been able to input yeah I love it and I'm a mother of two young boys um almost 10 they would say and almost seven um and the 10 year old almost 10 year old will give the almost seven year old a head start because of course he's um he is he's got a little bit shorter than the other one and I'll watch the youngest my youngest um do really well to begin
实际上，如果有人因为脚部状况极其糟糕而不得不退出超级马拉松比赛，重要的是不要只关注获胜，甚至不要只关注运动员的表现和获得的荣誉。而是我如何帮助那位运动员，是的，取得成功，但要以符合他们自身价值观的方式取得成功，而不是回到“手表或测量数据说了什么”这种老路上。我是否在用他们的成功来衡量我自己的成功？因为那离我们真正能投入的东西差得太远了。是的，我喜欢这样。我是两个小男孩的母亲，快10岁了，他们会说快7岁了。快10岁的那个会给快7岁的那个一点领先优势，因为他个子比另一个矮一点。我会看着我最小的孩子，他一开始做得很好，
with until he starts to consider where is my brother at which point he looks over his shoulder slows back because he's almost like going backwards and it's like you've got to keep looking forwards you've got to keep looking forwards because that means he loses the race every time because he's so concerned about who's coming from behind there is um in the book I wrote before 10 pillars it's called I can the teenage athlete's guide to mental fitness and in that I interview um an athlete called Kath Bishop and she's brilliant to follow on social media for anyone she's just got such an amazing perspective and she's got a brilliant book as well called the long win where she kind of re reimagines what success should look like but when I interviewed her and I've known her for many years now she talks about she did two olympics in rowing where
直到他开始考虑哥哥在哪里，这时他回头看了一眼，速度就慢了下来，就像在倒退一样。你必须一直向前看，一直向前看，因为这意味着他每次都会输掉比赛，因为他太关心后面的人了。在我写《10大支柱》之前，我写过一本书叫《我能：青少年运动员心理健康指南》，在书中我采访了一位叫凯丝·毕晓普的运动员。她在社交媒体上非常值得关注，她的视角非常独特。她还有一本很棒的书叫《长期的胜利》，她在书中重新构想了成功的样子。当我采访她时，我已经认识她很多年了，她谈到她参加过两届奥运会赛艇比赛，
um everything was on winning and they didn't win that was all that was cared about which which way were you going to go when you got on the plane home if you won a gold you've got to go in the front of the plane otherwise you went in the back and then she came to her third olympics and it was going to be her last olympics because she's highly highly intelligent and she was going off to the foreign office to become a diplomat so she knew it was her last and she and and her partner, Kath Granger, went with the approach of let's just see what's possible. Let's move away from this whole we must win. Let's see what's possible. Let's focus on the input. Everything they did with the what's possible approach. And so in the final. She was really conscious of I cannot think about the outcome,
一切都为了赢，但他们没赢，那是当时唯一在乎的事情。当你坐飞机回家时，你会走哪条路？如果你赢了金牌，你可以走飞机前舱，否则就得走后舱。后来她参加了第三届奥运会，那将是她的最后一届，因为她非常聪明，要去外交部当外交官，所以她知道这是最后一次。她和搭档凯丝·格兰杰采取的方法是：让我们看看能做到什么程度。让我们摆脱“我们必须赢”的想法。让我们看看能做到什么。让我们专注于投入。她们用“看看能做到什么”的方法做了所有事情。所以在决赛中，她非常清醒地意识到：我不能去想结果，
because as soon as you think about the outcome in a boat, you'll catch a crab. And you're done for in Olympics. It just takes one mistake and there's no chance. So she was just focused. What do I need to do in this moment? What's the thing in this moment to make the boat go fastest? And they got a silver medal. And so when she stopped trying to win, she did brilliantlyiantly but the winning causes us to slow down to look backwards to to panic and not do things so well so i love the way kath talks about it because it's always like what can i do at this moment and how do i stop thinking success is an individual result success is so much bigger than that but sometimes we need that perspective backwards to
因为一旦你在船上想到结果，你就会划桨失误（catch a crab）。在奥运会上你就完了。只需要一个错误，就没机会了。所以她只是专注于：此时此刻我需要做什么？此时此刻什么能让船划得最快？她们最终获得了银牌。所以当她不再试图去赢时，她表现得非常出色。但“赢”这个念头让我们慢下来，让我们回头看，让我们恐慌，从而导致事情做得不够好。所以我喜欢凯丝谈论它的方式，因为它总是关于“此时此刻我能做什么”，以及我如何停止认为成功只是一个个人结果。成功远不止于此，但有时我们需要那种回顾的视角，
be able to see that success for them was being able to focus on what mattered lovely and i think that's again so relevant to our audience of aspiring psychologists right now because you might lose your train of thought if you suddenly think about this answer could be the difference between getting offered a place getting offered a reserve place or getting told thanks but no thanks and so let's just think about making these moments the best they can be yeah and I don't something I found can be really helpful with any type of interview element is thinking about it on a more balanced basis so absolutely it's lovely to be offered a place or a role but it's also your career and you need to know that it's the right place for you and so being able to think kind of this is just as much for me to see whether this is the
才能看到对他们来说，成功就是能够专注于重要的事情。太好了，我认为这对于我们现在的心理学准从业者来说也非常相关。因为如果你突然想到“这个答案可能决定我是否能获得录取名额、候补名额，或者被告知谢谢但不用了”，你可能会失去思路。所以让我们专注于让这些时刻尽可能地美好。是的，我发现对于任何类型的面试环节，从更平衡的角度去思考真的很有帮助。当然，获得一个名额或职位很好，但这也是你的职业生涯，你需要知道这是否是适合你的地方。所以能够思考“这同样也是我观察这里是否是
right place and and actually if you know your values well enough and what matters to you and what you want to go and do some of those roles you might be going for aren't going to give you that and it's really hard to be really focused on what matters most But you're going to end up in the right place if you do. So being able to be really clear and not give the right answers, but give the answers that are authentic to you, will see you in the right place. And so the more you're focused in an interview then on my values and what matters and how am I being authentic,
合适的地方”的机会。实际上，如果你足够了解自己的价值观，了解什么对你重要，你想去做什么，那么你申请的一些职位可能并不能给你带来这些。专注于最重要的事情确实很难，但如果你做到了，你最终会去到正确的地方。所以能够非常清晰地表达，不是给出“正确”的答案，而是给出对你来说真实的答案，会让你去到正确的地方。因此，在面试中，你越专注于我的价值观、什么重要以及我如何保持真实，
not on do they give me a place or not you are more likely to get the right places offered to you absolutely I could not agree more um just before we share the best ways to get in contact with you and connect with you could you give us your top tip for reducing burnout in the psychology profession and on the way to getting to be where where you want to be oh goodness um this is a so hard because it is competitive and you do want to be brilliant and we're all in this because we want to help people live their lives better and that feels very important so you need to take it very seriously there was one book that really changed my life called essentialism and it's a guy called greg mccowan who talks about when we are really
而不是他们是否给我名额，你就越有可能获得合适的职位。绝对同意，我不能再同意了。在我们分享与你联系的最佳方式之前，你能给我们一个减少心理学行业职业倦怠的秘诀吗？以及在通往你想去的地方的过程中，如何保持状态？天哪，这太难了，因为竞争很激烈，你确实想变得出色。我们都在这里是因为我们想帮助人们更好地生活，这感觉非常重要，所以你需要非常认真地对待它。有一本书真的改变了我的生活，叫《精要主义》（Essentialism），作者是格雷格·麦吉翁。他谈到当我们真正
clear what matters to us and what we want to do and we put in place some boundaries to achieve that we get to say no to a lot more things and And those no's are normally the thing that when you wake up on a Tuesday morning, and it's that afternoon, you're like, oh, why did I say yes to that? And they're the things we normally say yes to out of fear or obligation or guilt. When we say yes to those things that don't take us in the right direction, we're basically saying no to the things that do because we're not giving ourselves the headspace to make the right decisions or to even go out and hunt we might say yes to things that come to us but we're not going out to hunt for the stuff that will
清楚什么对我们重要，我们想做什么，并为此设定一些界限时，我们就能对更多事情说“不”。而那些“不”通常就是当你周二早上醒来，想到那天下午的事情时，你会想“哦，我为什么要答应那个？”。这些通常是我们出于恐惧、义务或内疚而答应的事情。当我们答应那些不能带我们走向正确方向的事情时，我们基本上是在对那些正确的事情说“不”，因为我们没有给自己留出空间来做出正确的决定，甚至没有去寻找机会。我们可能会答应找上门来的事情，但我们并没有主动去寻找那些能
actively get us where we want to go and so I tend to have five filters that I work with with my clients that can help them make better decisions in that way so they have less burnout because they've got more energy for the stuff they really want so the filters do I have the capacity or do I have the capability to do this well so they don't end up in stress will I enjoy it because life shouldn't be a struggle all the time. There should be some fun stuff too. Does it help me meet my purpose? And you'll come on to purpose in chapter four of 10 pillars. And that was super, super crucial. And then does it meet one of my values? And we're never going to meet all five of those. I mean, amazing if we do, but very unlikely. But if you can have two or three
真正带我们去到想去的地方的事情。所以我倾向于有五个过滤器，我和我的客户一起使用，可以帮助他们做出更好的决定，从而减少职业倦怠，因为他们有更多的精力去做他们真正想做的事情。这些过滤器是：我有能力或有条件把这件事做好吗？这样他们就不会陷入压力。我会享受它吗？因为生活不应该总是挣扎，也应该有一些有趣的事情。它能帮助我实现目标吗？你会在《10大支柱》的第四章读到关于目标的内容，那非常非常关键。最后，它符合我的价值观吗？我们永远不可能满足所有这五个条件，如果能做到当然很棒，但不太可能。但如果你能满足其中两三个，
of them in place when you've got a decision to make on something then you're going to make far better decisions and then you're going to enjoy what you're doing so it doesn't feel like such hard work and then it reduces burnout or risk of burnout amazing thank you so much um i found this fascinating where can people learn more about you and your work josie so i have a web page called performance in mind.co.uk and there's a section on there called performance zone that has lots of blogs and worksheets and things you can download and use um i have the 10 pillars of success, which is 10 psychological traits, characteristics that all the research and evidence shows make you more successful. So things like belonging that we talked about, gratitude, courage, confidence, and then each chapter has
在做决定时，你就能做出更好的选择，然后你会享受你正在做的事情，这样就不会觉得那么辛苦，从而减少职业倦怠或倦怠的风险。太棒了，非常感谢。我觉得这非常引人入胜。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你的工作，乔西？我有一个网页叫performanceinmind.co.uk，上面有一个部分叫“表现区”（performance zone），里面有很多博客、工作表和你可以下载使用的东西。我有《成功的10大支柱》，里面有10个心理特质，所有的研究和证据都表明这些特质能让你更成功。比如我们谈到的归属感、感恩、勇气、自信。每一章都有
a person that you've probably heard of that brings them to life and has really used that in order to be successful. Then I've got the I Can Teenage Guide to Mental Fitness, which is designed for sports, but people also use it for music and things, which is full of worksheets on how to to um how to handle setbacks how to be more confident um and then I spend way too much of my time on Twitter so I am Josephine Parry on Twitter and I try and put out lots of kind of activities and tools that people can use on there amazing thank you and I'd seen on Twitter that you've not long recently done the London Marathon as well. So well done to you. Thank you. Yes, I think that will be the last marathon in a while. We're going to focus on something short and less painful for a little while.
一个你可能听说过的人，他们让这些特质变得生动，并真正利用它们取得了成功。然后我有《我能：青少年心理健康指南》，它是为体育设计的，但人们也用它来处理音乐等方面的问题。里面充满了关于如何处理挫折、如何变得更自信的工作表。我花在Twitter上的时间太多了，所以我是Josephine Parry，我尽量在上面发布很多人们可以使用的活动和工具。太棒了，谢谢。我在Twitter上看到你最近刚跑完了伦敦马拉松。做得好。谢谢。是的，我想那会是近期最后一次马拉松了。我们打算在一段时间内专注于一些更短、痛苦更少的事情。
Well, it's been such a privilege to speak to you and a pleasure. And I'm sorry I've kept you much longer than I advertised so thank you again right just one thing actually um if anyone does want to get into sports psychology um I have um a clinic every Monday morning that's free sessions for people to book into um to come and ask anything about kind of how it might work with their personal situation or kind of the training they've done to date so you can find details about that on my website but that's a way to get much more personal information on sports psychology ideal thank you so much and thank you for illuminating this career which sounds incredible but also quite tricky as well at times thank you oh i loved it I loved it I loved it I loved it um thank you again Dr Josephine and please please do follow her on all of her socials and if you are an aspiring sport and exercise
好吧，能和你交谈真是我的荣幸，非常愉快。很抱歉我占用了你比预定时间长得多的时间，所以再次感谢你。对了，只有一件事，如果有人真的想进入运动心理学领域，我每周一早上都有一个诊所，提供免费的预约时段，人们可以来询问任何关于它如何与他们的个人情况相适应，或者他们迄今为止所做的培训的问题。你可以在我的网站上找到相关详情，这是获取关于运动心理学更个性化信息的一种方式。太理想了，非常感谢。也感谢你阐明了这个职业，它听起来令人难以置信，但有时也相当棘手。谢谢。哦，我喜欢它，我喜欢它，我喜欢它。再次感谢你，约瑟芬博士。请务必在她的所有社交媒体上关注她。如果你是一位有抱负的运动和锻炼
psychologist do consider her clinic that she runs once a week to come and connect with me on my socials Dr Marianne Trent all of the resources we have mentioned in today's episode are in the show notes and in the description if you're watching on youtube please do like and subscribe to the channel if you are watching on youtube and listen out for the next episode which will be available to you from monday at 6 a.m take care Thank you. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide.
心理学家，请考虑她每周举办一次的诊所。欢迎在我的社交媒体上与我联系，玛丽安·特伦特博士。我们在今天节目中提到的所有资源都在节目说明和描述中。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必点赞并订阅频道。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请留意下一集，它将于周一早上6点发布。保重。谢谢。有抱负的心理学家集体。有抱负的心理学家集体。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be OK. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有这个播客在身边，你就会走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为一名心理学家没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，觉得“不，我没有做错”，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。